i
[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr de
lenski pidió evacuar la provincia de
donges tras el ataque contra la cartel
de all en ifca que causó la muerte de 50
prisioneros de guerra ucranianos
tanto moscú como kiev niegan la autoría
del ataque
en francia la mitad de los departamentos
están en crisis de agua y la mayoría
bajo restricciones de uso de agua
medidas extremas para hacer frente a la
devastadora sequía que atraviesa el país
en guatemala la comitiva del presidente
alejandro giammattei fue atacada con
disparos a su paso por una aldea del
departamento de huehuetenango el
presidente salió ileso del incidente
tenemos reporte
buenas noches bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24
soy rosa pérez más de hoy y es para mí
un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
de ucrania porque el presidente del país
volodymyr selenski ordenó la evacuación
de la región de donges bajo bombardeo de
las fuerzas rusas el mandatario pidió la
salida de los civiles para evitar más
muertes en el que es el principal
escenario de los enfrentamientos entre
moscú y kiev selenski agregó que los
residentes que abandonen la zona
recibirán una compensación pues notó si
tiene la oportunidad por favor hable con
los que siguen permaneciendo en las
zonas de combate en el donbass por favor
convenza a los de que es necesario irse
especialmente si son familias con niños
si tiene la oportunidad de ayudar a las
personas desplazadas hágalo
seguimos en ucrania pero vamos a
mykolaiv un puerto estratégico del mar
negro las fuerzas rusas llegaron a estar
a pocos kilómetros del centro de la
ciudad
el ejército de ucrania hizo retroceder
al ejército ruso pero mykolaiv estando
al alcance de la artillería rusa y los
ataques se han intensificado ahora que
el gobierno de ucrania ha lanzado una
contraofensiva para retomar el control
de la zona el informe es de catalina
gómez ángel giorgio al andrés gallardo
oleg y su mujer observan lo que queda
del colegio de varias generaciones se
han educado
en este salón hacíamos las reuniones de
antiguos alumnos ahora no hay nada que
vamos a hacer juntos tres misiles han
caído horas antes en este sector del sur
de la ciudad de mykolaiv que ha sido
golpeado permanentemente desde el
comienzo de la guerra decenas de
viviendas han quedado dañadas es el caso
de la casa de ludmila que en marzo ya
vio volar por los aires el techo de la
cocina la onda expansiva de este nuevo
ataque ha roto las ventanas y ha dejado
las paredes agrietadas
no sabemos qué quieren de nosotros todos
los días nos atacan no pasa día ni noche
sin que lo hagan no sabemos cuál fue la
última noche que dormimos bien
su marido tiene cáncer y me ven con una
pensión que apenas les alcanza en este
sótano han pasado la mayor parte de los
últimos cinco meses
dónde vamos y qué hacemos no sabemos
nada de
la resistencia a los ucranianos también
se ve reflejada en la rapidez con la que
arreglan los daños pero algunas veces
los hombres no dan abasto
muchas veces un solo ataque afecta hasta
30 casas cada vez hay más destrucción
desde la mañana esta es la quinta casa
que reparo
los ataques contra mykolaiv se han
intensificado desde que comenzó la
contraofensiva a las fuerzas ucranianas
para retomar la vecina ciudad de gerzón
a 45 kilómetros al sur este colegio
también fue atacado días antes cuando
uno les cuenta a los amigos y familiares
que están en rusia lo que está pasando
dicen que no es verdad como que no es
verdad miralo
andrei es uno de los profesores quiere
ser testigo lo que ha sucedido
no puedo entender como las escuelas
pueden molestar a la gente los
habitantes de mi cola ya están pagando
un alto precio en esta guerra muchas
personas mueren cuando salen a la calle
aún así la vida en la ciudad es más
activa que meses atrás
continuamos en europa pero cambiamos de
información españa reportó la segunda
muerte relacionada con la viruela del
mono en el país junto con el
fallecimiento que confirmó brasil son
los tres únicos decesos que se han
detectado fuera de áfrica donde se
encuentran los 12 países en los que el
brote es endémico les contamos más en
este informe
a raíz del aumento de contagios por
viruela del mono las autoridades
mundiales se han puesto en alerta según
el último censo se han registrado más de
1000 casos en brasil en esa nación ya se
ha informado de la primera muerte
relacionada con el virus
el ministerio de salud ha sido
notificado sobre una muerte relacionada
con la viruela del mono se trata de un
paciente con otras comorbilidades
relevantes y con antecedentes de
tratamiento de quimioterapia y había
indicios de que el motivo de la muerte
estaba relacionado con el virus también
se han registrado dos muertes en el
continente europeo en españa esto eleva
el número total de muertes relacionadas
con la viruela del mono a tres fuera de
áfrica donde la enfermedad endémica se
detectó por primera vez en humanos hace
más de 50 años la enfermedad que provoca
fiebre alta inflamación de los ganglios
linfáticos y una erupción parecida a la
varicela afecta principalmente a los
hombres que tienen relaciones sexuales
con otros hombres pero las autoridades
han advertido de los riesgos de
estigmatizar a una comunidad concreta y
íntima no a ese tipo
texto si se demoniza a la gente deja
hablar de ello o no busca ayuda médica o
no informan de los casos y una vez que
cualquier virus o cualquier infección
pasa a la clandestinidad es imposible de
rastrear y de repente vemos una
explosión de muchísimos casos de
explosión y mexiquense que desde mayo se
han detectado unos 18.000 casos de
viruela del mono en todo el mundo lo que
ha llevado a la organización mundial de
la salud a declarar la emergencia
sanitaria mundial el organismo rector
también está animando a la vacunación de
las poblaciones de riesgo pero afirma
que el número de vacunas disponibles en
todo el mundo sigue siendo insuficiente
mientras tanto las autoridades
sanitarias recomiendan a las personas
expuestas a la enfermedad vírica que
tomen más precauciones de seguridad y
limiten su número de parejas sexuales
vamos ahora con información climática
porque en francia el lago de sabón son
en los alpes tiene 13 metros menos de
caudal de lo habitual el río lago está
en su punto más bajo son las imágenes de
un país con la mitad de sus
departamentos en crisis por falta de
agua un hecho cada vez más recurrente
nos informa lluís muñoz
christophe tchao es un policía del
departamento para la biodiversidad en
esta casa han visto que el césped está
demasiado verde por lo que los
propietarios podrían estar saltándose
las restricciones de agua que tiene
francia por el momento han estado
haciendo pedagogía pero las multas para
los infractores podrían ir de los 1.500
euros a los particulares hasta los 7 mil
euros para empresas
puede haber conflictos de uso lo
descubriremos sobre la marcha pero es
probable que vaya a haber restricciones
mucho más fuertes para preservar el agua
potable para promover la salud pública y
compartir el recurso
291 de 96 departamentos tienen
restricciones de uso de agua para la
mitad han declarado la crisis es el mes
de julio más seco desde 1959 una
tendencia que se viene repitiendo
liberó ese look cuarto tuvimos un
invierno muy seco y una primavera
excepcionalmente seca que no se veía
desde 1871 con las temperaturas más
altas pues no voy a decir que el año va
a ser igual pero sí que es muy
preocupante porque es recurrente aunque
el caso es que a éxito exclusivo
ríos lagos y pantanos están en su punto
más bajo como por ejemplo este lago
lebrock cerca de niza en el sur de
francia
la sequía tiene grandes impactos la
cosecha de cereal será un 30% menor
algunos reactores nucleares han tenido
que bajar su producción porque el agua
que devuelven a los ríos tiene una
temperatura mayor y puede afectar a los
ecosistemas y sobre todo aumenta el
riesgo de incendios
continuamos con más información
climática pero vamos ahora a eeuu las
autoridades estatales de kentucky
reportaron este sábado que las
inundaciones del pasado miércoles y
jueves causaron al menos 25 fallecidos
una cifra que puede crecer en las
próximas horas según informó el
gobernador del estado mientras tanto
continúan las labores de rescate al
tiempo que la situación parece más
estable en el terreno los supervivientes
cuentan como de un momento a otro se
esfumó parte de sus vidas marta moya con
los detalles
sobrevivir a una verdadera catástrofe
mientras continúa el balance de las
autoridades por las devastadoras
inundaciones que sacudieron el estado
estadounidense de kentucky
los supervivientes relatan cómo lo
vivieron una coste y me hizo levantarme
a las dos y media de la madrugada a las
tres el agua ya se estaba aproximando al
interior de la casa aunque todavía no
estaba dentro en seguida fue acercándose
y el cauce creciendo en un momento dado
miramos a la puerta principal y mi carro
y el de mi vecino estaban jugando los
autos de choque como botes de choque en
medio de nuestro patio delantero según
el jefe de bomberos voluntarios del
estado todo ocurrió muy rápido clifford
y merckx
las carreteras se volvieron
intransitables en 30 o 40 minutos lo que
era un leve arroyo o un cauce junto a la
carretera se convirtió en un torrente de
agua y para cuando todo el mundo se
despertó a la mañana siguiente había
vidas destruidas por los perdidos y
gente sin movilidad volver a la guardia
nacional continúa trabajando en las
tareas de rescate al tiempo que las
autoridades estatales ya reportaron
varias decenas de fallecidos cifra que
podría ir en aumento pese a la
estabilización de la situación
y el agua del río a 3 metros las fugas
son casi nulas ya no existe una
situación de peligro y la carretera está
de nuevo abierta todas las vallas han
sido retiradas aquí
las inundaciones de este julio son el
segundo fenómeno climatológico extremo
que vive kentucky en menos de un año los
expertos advierten que estos fenómenos
serán cada vez más recurrentes
seguimos en eeuu el presidente joe biden
volvió a dar positivo por kobe 19 este
sábado tres días después de salir del
aislamiento en el que se encontraba el
mandatario de 79 años volverá a entrar
en cuarentena cinco días más por lo que
canceló los viajes que tenía previstos a
michigan y delaware el médico del
presidente aseguró que biden continúa
sin presentar síntomas y atribuyó el
resultado positivo a la efecto rebote de
la pastilla antirretroviral que tomó el
mandatario para combatir el virus
vamos ahora a centroamérica porque hace
unas horas conocíamos el ataque contra
la comitiva del presidente de guatemala
alejandro giammattei sin embargo el
mandatario habría resultado ileso del
incidente
previamente conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal andrés suárez jaramillo que
nos amplió la información desde la
ciudad de guatemala de acuerdo con
información oficial con el vocero del
ejército de guatemala el coronel rubén
téllez lo que se habría producido hoy es
un ataque contra el cuerpo de seguridad
contra el operativo perimetral del
ejército que se encontraba custodiando
al presidente alejandro giammatei en el
noroccidente de guatemala de acuerdo con
esta versión el presidente llegó en
helicóptero a huehuetenango y a dos
kilómetros de allí una de las patrullas
que se encontraba custodiando al
presidente interceptó un vehículo que se
dirigía hacia el helipuerto donde se
encontraba el presidente este vehículo
integrado por cinco individuos
fuertemente armados comenzó abrió fuego
comenzó un cruce de disparos
con la patrulla del ejército uno de los
entrega integrantes uno de los
tripulantes resultó herido en su pierna
cayó al suelo fue capturado
inmediatamente llevado a un puesto de
salud y luego puesto a disposición de la
policía nacional guatemalteca y de la
fiscalía general de la nación fue
identificado como josué lópez
posiblemente integrante del cartel nuevo
jalisco y de nacionalidad mexicana los
otros cuatro integrantes habrían
escapado a mexico ya que la frontera es
muy cercana pero como los ejércitos se
habían coordinado fue muy pronto a la
captura de estos cuatro sujetos que son
de nacionalidad guatemalteca el
presidente salió ileso pero recordemos
que están parte norte del país tiene una
presencia muy alta del cartel nuevo
jalisco
y cerramos con una buena noticia porque
este sábado la última superviviente del
tiroteo de balde salió del hospital dos
meses después de resultar herida en el
ataque de la escuela primaria en el que
murieron 19 menores y dos profesores
maya zamora de 10 años entregó flores a
médicos y enfermeras al ser dada de alta
del hospital universitario de san
antonio
y con estas imágenes cerramos esta
edición sigan con nosotros
[Música]